[Music]
ryan is in phoenix hey ryan how are you
i'm doing good how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
well
my sister and her husband they're having
some marriage troubles and she's moved
into our house just for a couple days
because of some arguments over finance
he wants to make a dungeons and dragons
man cave and take out a twenty thousand
dollar omega
that's an oxymoron that is not a man
cave okay go ahead
well played
yeah how old is this boy
uh he's in his 20s upper 20s wow wow
okay he wants to take out a don't you
want some dungeon and dragons man cave
and uh so what and he's wanting to spend
money she doesn't want to spend is that
it
yeah so she would have to sign in sign
on with the home equity loan oh he wants
to borrow money for it yes it's to
borrow money to take a home equity loan
for it and how much how much are we
going to spend on said cave
uh they're looking to do a twenty
thousand dollar loan
that's quite a dungeon and it must have
real dragons
i think it does
certainly certainly one that moves and
maybe breathes some smoke for that kind
of money wow
he's got some big visions
but the problem here is it's really
driving a wedge between them and their
marriage and i need some help so she's
living with me right now
i need some help in knowing how i can
help guide them give them some good
advice
and in what they're doing so they can
get through this what kind of income
what kind of household income do they
have
uh they've got to be around 50k a year
okay
all right
so as much as i want to make fun of it
i'll sidestep that for a second because
it's just it's too easy but um i can
understand that
um but but let's just say that
virtually anything you want to do that's
legal and moral with money i'm fine with
it's your money okay so if you want to
build a dungeons and dragons man cave
it's not probably on the list of things
that'll happen in my lifetime for me but
that's okay if you want to do that
that's all right
and
the trick the trick would be a couple
things you would have to use
uh you'd have to have several basic
principles that you followed okay so
whether it's in my case my version of
that is i own too many firearms
okay
and absolutely an absurd number just
because i'm a collector okay
and uh so that's the same that's just as
stupid to some people as this is to uh
other people right so same thing but in
that case so here's what would have to
happen a
i would need to pay cash number one
i can't pay cash for my
um
absurd hobbies
mine is guns his is this okay
then you don't do it it's it's out of
range
okay number two
uh it needs to be when i'm done with the
whole thing a small percentage of my net
worth and income
so in other words if i have if i make 30
000 a year and i have 400 000 worth of
firearms that's asinine
that makes sense okay
and so it needs to be a small percentage
of your world because it is a hobby
for fun
by definition and when your fun takes up
too much of your life it no longer is
fun when you're like a grown-up and
stuff
okay so one we're gonna pay cash two it
needs to be a small percentage
and three here's the hard one here
and this is where the rubber meets the
road on this one even more than the
other two
it can't
i can't put my selfish desires in front
of the needs and wants of my family
right and so if i
in my case i'm using my firearms as the
absurd thing if i am doing that and my
wife doesn't have a good car
well that's a little boy wanting to
collect hunting guns or or collect guns
okay
and uh and i'm so i'm i'm putting my
desires ahead of the good of my overall
family my children's college fund isn't
funded but i bought a new gun
that's a child
not a man
that's a child not a woman when she puts
a six thousand dollar purse
on the shelf and her children's college
fund isn't funded that's a child
and right ain't no coach in the world
worth that if your kid isn't going to
school
okay so that's where the problem is here
all three of these are violated in this
case
and it has nothing to do with dungeons
and dragons or the weirdness of all that
it has everything to do with a he's
borrowing money b he can't afford it and
see the big deal for me is if i'm her
brother
if i'm you
is that he is putting his little selfish
wants ahead of the needs of his own wife
and i think that's how we've been seeing
it too you know it's it does seem
childish but
we the problem is it's i mean we have
problems in the past with it and
everything with those two but it's hard
to get them on the same page you know
it's just well because because they're
immature
right i mean she's put her foot down
she's she's got him out of credit card
debt she married him so she's immature
there you go
because he's immature beyond belief
emotional right
he's a little baby boy that wants his
little thing
and he's having a little fit and that
puts her in the seat of mommy
instead of the seat of white
certification yeah yeah it is so and so
what they need what they desperately
need is not financial counseling they
need marriage counseling
right
and he had that degree yeah and so if
you want to pay for something don't pay
for financial peace university it won't
help them
okay pay for marriage counseling get
them in with a good pastor a good
marriage counselor that can help these
two grow up
but when she married this guy she knew
he was weird
yeah i think i think it went pretty
quick and
and then it just went they got into it
so yeah
doesn't matter
listen i've gotten into some things i've
gotten into some things really quick too
and when i was an immature
little baby child i put my
selfish desires in front of my wife's
and um we've been married 40 years and
she says we've had 33 good years of
marriage and it was the years where i
put my selfish desire there
that she's laughing about they're not
fun they're funny now they weren't funny
back then
hopefully someday they can heal them
their marriage and both of them
emotionally mature
in this process and they can look back
and laugh at the absurdity of we almost
lost our marriage over a dungeons and
dragons man cave i mean that really 30
years later has got to be funny i'm just
saying
it's funny for it's almost funny right
now honestly i mean we we've laughed and
it's laughing and then then you think
wait a second this is for real
and it's causing it's causing a divorce
oh my gosh i mean she had to move out
yeah it got bad but hopefully you might
have a problem with your hobby if dot
dot dot right
when they get on the same page as a
married couple then the finances can get
on the same page but dave is absolutely
right this is a full alarm marriage
issues got to be dealt with then the
money can take
uh the next priority piece but right now
there's bigger issues going on here so
here's a way to meet him
okay
i don't you know i would tell her to
tell him this i don't have a problem
with you building a man cave
i do have a problem
with your putting your needs
or your selfish self in front of the
good of our family and our marriage i do
have a problem with borrowing money to
do it and i do have a problem with
spending money that is an excessive
amount considering
our current financial state
and uh but if we can get all of those
things straightened out and you want to
build a man cave someday that with cash
and that is a small percentage of our
world even if i don't understand the
whole thing we can do that
all right and uh but in other words it's
not no it's not now i'm not using these
principles
right
right and i think you're right it does
come down to just changing and uh that's
through christ so examine your prayers
we'll keep them in ours exactly yeah and
you know if you can get them in with a
good pastor this may be the thing that
creates a whole spiritual movement in
their marriage that facilitates
the emotional maturity that helps cause
it to grow up because one thing about a
powerful spiritual walk is one of the
things it'll always teach you is to not
be so dadgum selfish and self-centered
and it's the main problem with every
marriage by the way including ken's
[Laughter]
hey let's go to commercial shall we and
mine this is the ramsay show